[Música]
se reducirá el número de diputados en El
Salvador el presidente nayib bukele
firmó la reforma al código electoral que
había sido aprobada la madrugada de este
miércoles de esta manera la próxima
legislatura el número de parlamentarios
pasará de 84 a 60
polémica en México el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador reconoció que
militares ejecutaron a cinco personas
tal como lo muestra un video difundido
por medios internacionales según el
mandatario los involucrados están
detenidos y se investiga lo sucedido
los incendios forestales en Canadá
elevan las alarmas ambientales en
Estados Unidos autoridades cifran en 100
millones las personas que están bajo
alerta por la baja calidad del aire en
cerca de 18 estados de la Unión
Americana
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda a Andrés Meza Muñoz iniciamos en
El Salvador el presidente nayib bukele
firmó la reforma que reduce el número de
parlamentarios en el congreso la
propuesta promovida por el propio
mandatario había sido aprobada en la
madrugada de este miércoles y entrará en
vigor a partir de la próxima legislatura
según el gobierno con La Iniciativa
también se pretende reducir los gastos
del estado y promover la igualdad del
voto
favor acabo de firmar la reforma al
código electoral que reduce el número de
diputados de 84 a 60 como era antes de
los falsos acuerdos de paz y elimina los
diputados por residuo dejando únicamente
los diputados asignados por cantidad de
votos México es escenario de un nuevo
hecho de violencia esta vez en la ciudad
de Nuevo Laredo allí un grupo de
soldados detuvieron de manera violenta a
cinco personas presuntamente integrantes
del narco que luego fallecieron producto
de un supuesto intercambio de disparos
el presidente mexicano calificó El hecho
como una aparente ejecución
extrajudicial
una pregunta ejecución extrajudicial así
catalogan autoridades y medios de prensa
El último hecho de violencia registrado
en la ciudad mexicana de Nuevo Laredo un
video captado por una cámara de
seguridad muestra una persecución que
resulta en un accidente automovilístico
segundos después una decena de soldados
se acerca la auto accidentado en el que
circulaban un grupo de civiles
supuestamente armados y proceden a
detenerlos los presuntos delincuentes
son golpeados y colocados estando
inmovilizados contra una cerca
perimetral luego se ve como los
uniformados abren Fuego contra un
enemigo invisible pues no se ve en el
cuadro de la imagen al final los
detenidos terminan muertos solo uno
sobrevivió pero falleció más tarde por
sus heridas los hechos ocurrieron el
pasado 18 de mayo al parecer
sí hubo ajusticiamiento
y eso no se puede permitir nosotros no
somos iguales
a los anteriores gobiernos Entonces
cuando hay un abuso cuando hay un exceso
cuando se violan Derechos Humanos
tiene que
castigarse a los responsables el martes
en la secretaría de defensa nacional
informó que la fiscalía general de la
república llevaría el peso de las
investigaciones al estar involucrados
civiles la fiscalía general de Justicia
militar en el ámbito de su competencia
desde el momento que se dio a conocer
este material bibliográfico editado
inició de oficio una investigación de
los hechos para deslindar las
responsabilidades derivadas de la
legislación militar no es la primera vez
que Nuevo Laredo es escenario de un
hecho de violencia similar cuatro meses
antes cinco jóvenes fueron asesinados y
uno quedó mal herido al ser
interceptados por uniformados
al menos una docena de estados de
Estados Unidos sufren las consecuencias
de los incendios forestales en Canadá ya
que el humo ha llegado hasta el vecino
país con un recorrido hacia el sur las
autoridades señalan que cien millones de
personas están bajo alerta por la baja
calidad del aire
bajo alerta por la mala calidad del aire
así están varios estados en Estados
Unidos el motivo el humo de cientos de
incendios forestales en Canadá que se
está moviendo hacia el sur y afectando
al país vecino
podemos verlo leerlo y sentirlo y es
alarmante Y preocupante ayer a las 10 de
la noche el índice de la calidad del
aire alcanzó 218 un nivel muy poco
saludable
Este es un evento sin precedentes en
nuestra ciudad y debemos tomar
precauciones
ciudades como Nueva York Washington o
Filadelfia entre otras están bajo una
Niebla de color naranja que está
afectando a la población con como
escozor de ojos y de garganta
no no puedo respirar se me hace difícil
respirar
si tenía programado un examen para
renovar mi licencia de conducir hoy y
Fue cancelado me siento muy triste
algo que según los expertos puede
resultar muy peligroso para la salud en
especial para los pulmones para lo que
recomiendan no hacer ningún esfuerzo
físico
el mayor peligro es para las poblaciones
más jóvenes especialmente para los que
tienen los pulmones en desarrollo y por
supuesto ancianos que tengan
enfermedades respiratorias crónicas o de
otro tipo
ahora las autoridades aseguran que se
espera que los niveles de contaminación
se reduzcan no obstante la recomendación
sigue siendo permanecer en interiores a
no ser que sea por un motivo de fuerza
mayor
nuevos problemas legales para el
expresidente Donald Trump el
departamento de Justicia le notificó que
es objeto de una investigación sobre el
mal manejo de documentos clasificados se
trata de los cientos de documentos que
fueron hallados por el FBI el año pasado
en la mansión del exmandatario en
Florida según medios estadounidenses
esta notificación se le hace a personas
que tienen probabilidades de ser
imputadas para darles la oportunidad de
testificar antes de que se presenten
cargos en su contra
en Guatemala inició el juicio contra
nueve exmilitares señalados de asesinar
a 25 personas en una comunidad indígena
en el año 1982 y entre los que habían 17
menores de edad los hechos ocurrieron
durante el régimen militar de Efraín
Ríos montt desde antigua nuestro
corresponsal para Centroamérica Andrés
Suárez con los detalles un nuevo
capítulo judicial inició este miércoles
en Guatemala para determinar la
responsabilidad de los militares en una
masacre indígena ocurrida el 29 de julio
de 1982 este caso en particular se
denomina el de rancho bejuco que es el
caserío en el departamento de Baja
Verapaz donde presuntamente un grupo de
militares acorraló a 25 indígenas dentro
de una vivienda para luego bombardearlos
y de esta forma asesinarlos ante el
tribunal de mayor riesgo de en ciudad de
Guatemala deberán comparecer los
indicados desde comandante comisionados
hasta patrulleros por la muerte de estos
indígenas entre los que se cuentan 17
menores de entre los ocho meses y los 13
años de edad para la época el estado
estaba comandado por el ya fallecido
dictador Efraín Ríos montt un militar
golpista que fue protagonista de estos
largos 36 años de guerra civil en
Guatemala y dado que actualmente se
denuncia desde organismos
internacionales como locales que el
aparato judicial en Guatemala está
cooptado por los intereses de personas
muy poderosas puede que este llegue a
ser un juicio enrevesado basta con tener
el antecedente del 2022 del año pasado
cuando el juez Miguel Ángel Gálvez quien
envió a juicio a nueve militares por
secuestros desapariciones forzadas
asesinatos durante ese periodo de la
guerra civil tuvo que oír del país y hoy
se encuentra en el exilio en Bogotá hay
otras ciudades importantes de Colombia
Seguidores del presidente Gustavo Petro
marcharon para expresar su respaldo a su
gobierno el jefe de estado cuyo gobierno
está envuelto en un escándalo por
presuntas escuchas ilegales pidió al
congreso acelerar las discusiones de sus
principales reformas políticas
con música pancartas y trajes
tradicionales miles de Seguidores del
presidente Gustavo Petro salieron a las
calles para dejar constancia de que los
deseos de cambio en Colombia siguen
intactos
con el respaldo popular Gustavo Petro
aprovechó para instar al congreso a la
aprobación de sus reformas sociales
con toleto
le solicitamos
de nuestra propia humildad
le solicitamos desde nuestras ganas de
justicia y de paz
que aprueben la reformas que le
garantizan al pueblo colombiano sus
derechos
la movilización que en principio era
para respaldar las reformas se tornó en
favor del proyecto político de Petro
afectado recientemente por el escándalo
de escuchas ilegales que provocaron la
salida de su jefa de gabinete y del
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela en su
alocución Petro volvió a manifestarse en
contra de la interceptación de
comunicaciones de manera ilegal no
chozamos magistrados no chuzamos
periodistas no chozamos gente de la
oposición no violamos los derechos de la
humanidad en el territorio colombiano el
jefe de estado reiteró que para el
segundo semestre del año espera por
poner dos nuevas reformas dirigidas a
mejorar la educación y los servicios
públicos
hasta aquí es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]